hey everyone welcome back to another
video
in the angular series in today's video
we're going to be covering the topic of
angular components
so without further ado let's begin first
let's look at what's in store for us
first
we'll get acquainted to what exactly
angular components
are then i'll help you create an angular
component
by showing a quick demo and lastly we'll
learn about component decorator metadata
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel if you love
watching new and interesting technology
videos
also hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so what exactly are angular
components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct
now to help you understand what
components are consider them
as lego blocks now they basically are
combined
together to form the final application
so in this case
here we have the logo component then you
have a sign in component
an image component and then a create
account component
now all of these components generally
don't affect the working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are so to go ahead
let's discuss some of its common
features now firstly
they are the building blocks of an
application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component
and then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy and
these components are a subset of
directives
now don't worry about what deductives
are because we'll cover them later on in
the series
but to give you an idea there are three
types of directives you have the
structural directives
the attribute directives and the
component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now components are typically custom html
elements
and each of these elements can
instantiate only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component
now this class is then decorated with
the at component decorator
now the decorator accepts a metadata
object that gives information about the
component
now a component must belong to the ng
module
in order for it to be usable by another
component or application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components
when i show it to you practically so
let's head over to a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an
angular application called demo
components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on
getting started with angular that is
angular hello world i highly suggest you
go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so
now let's go ahead and create our first
component now the command used to create
our component is
ng gc and your component name
once executed it creates four different
files
now let's just see how this works on rvs
code
now what you can do is head to your
terminal and type in the command
ng g c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm going to just call my
component
text component all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files
you can see you have four different
files that have been created
and finally it updates the file that is
app.module.ts
indicating that this new component has
been created
so here in your source folder within
which there's an app folder
and again here you can see that your
four different files have been created
first is the html file where you can
define all the code that you want
for your component next you have the css
file for your
styling then you have the dot ts file
which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have
spec.ts which is basically a unit test
file
all right and then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been
imported that is what the message
conveys here all right now
let's go back to our app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so
let me just get rid of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna display a basic
heading saying hello
welcome all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser hello welcome message is
displayed
now let's go back to our component dot
html file and here let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h 3
and let me display a message saying
welcome
to this tutorial
on angular components all right
now in your text component dot ts file
which is your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component
now go ahead and copy this and in your
final component.html go ahead
and create your custom html tag with the
selector that you just copied
now this indicates that the component
that you just created
that is the text component is being
incorporated in the final render
so what happens is that whatever is
defined in the component.html file
is also being rendered in your final
output so
when i save this let's go ahead and
check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed
so this was a simple creation of a
component
now for this let's give it some styling
so
here go to your dot css file and provide
some styling
say for example here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing
and say each one
text align is center
all right so let me save this and there
we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component
now the components are executed
sequentially so now let's create another
component
just to give you a brief insight into it
let's say
nggc image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo
so i'll show you how that works now you
can see that
a new component has been created with
four files again
so in my assets folder here i've added
the logo
so what i can do is back in my html file
i can go ahead and create an image tag
so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say
this is the image component
[Music]
and then let me say
image source equals
so the source is basically assets
[Music]
slash logo dot png
and class equals
center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide
any sort of styling that you need so let
me just say
text align
to be center and then
let's create a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this and from the dot cs
file
let's copy the selector and create a
custom html tag in our final
component.html file
so there we go let's save this and check
the output
and there we go first the hello welcome
message is displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create your own
components
and don't forget to incorporate these
selectors into your final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata
now as mentioned earlier the at
component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object
first up is the selector now basically
the selector
is a css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component
you can create your own html tag however
the same has to be included in the
parent component
so to help you understand that better
let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it
to say n component
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser
the message is not displayed so what we
can do
is you can copy this selector
and then include this here
and now you can see that the same
component has been rendered onto your
output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for
the view now the template can be used to
provide some
particular markup the markup could
typically include
some headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view
so here you can see this is basically
the external file
that contains the template for the view
next up you have styles
now these are also inline defined styles
that can be applied to the components
view
so any code that you provide in the dot
css file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets
that are applied on your components view
next up you have providers
now this is again an array where certain
services can be registered for your
component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
however these are a little advanced as
we proceed in the series we'll
understand them better
i hope it really helped you if you have
any doubts or queries let us know in the
comment section below
we'll be back with new videos on angular
soon until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here